i've realized that the best way to make
money in property is not to own
properties to control property see this
big apartment block right here whoever
built this apartment block or whoever
owns these apartments might be renting
these out making a bit of money in fact
i tell you what i'll tell you how much
rent they're paying
so how much rent how much rent do people
pay to live in this apartment block 7.50
about 750 yeah okay so people are paying
750 pounds per month to live in the
apartment block let's go and have a look
around some of the apartments
they might be thinking 750 pounds 750
pound all these apartment blocks 750
pounds 750 pounds the landlords the
developers are getting rich but actually
let me show you something really really
interesting
beautiful oh nice
okay to come in yeah all right good
so you pay 750 yeah it looks lovely by
the way do you live here no so you pay
750 what do you do with this property if
you don't live here i rent it out on a
short term list so you rent it out like
on booking.com airbnb yeah all right
cool it looks fabulous i mean honestly
so so nice i like that life is short eat
dessert first that's great so how much
do your guests pay per night on average
to be here
90 pounds
nice you've done so well by the way
furnishing this it just looks good so
they pay 90 pounds a night you're paying
750. i don't need to be great at maths
to work out that you're in profit right
so how much on average how much profit
do you make from this property on
average average about 700 750 pounds
that's that's brilliant so you're
getting paid is that profit that's
profit so the landlord's charging 750.
he's got costs you're making profit of
750. yes that's incredible show me uh
show me the lounge
so that's the living room yeah this is
the bedroom nice
what made you decide to go visit bed
because our aim is for contractors and
this way we've got more target audience
for two people rather than just a couple
yes
very smart very smart um was it in good
condition when you got it did you have
to refurb it at all
right that's it and how much money did
you spend on total what was your down
payment on the all the furniture
painting deposit ran absolutely
everything how much did you pay so rate
750
just under three grand oh right did you
pay deposit no deposit how did you get
out of that one well i told you this is
not for a normal tenant yeah tenants
yeah tenants i'm a company right so
you'll be taking deposits off your
guests yes right perfect
perfect so okay i mean the views are
fabulous so i need i've got a couple of
questions firstly legalities is this
legal absolutely
why is it legal because it's through
management contracts so it's not
subletting
it's no different from what hotels do
when they rent the building and release
it out to guests every night it's the
same so okay so you've got the right
contracts you've got permission from the
landlord there's no head lease
restrictions on the block you've got
service you've got key safes outside
is this is does this really get booked
up do people really pay 90 pounds not to
be here i literally just had my 100
occupancy this month wow and you got a
booking this morning this morning how
much
uh well it was 90 pounds uh a night
she booked it for 43 nights 43 nights
that's literally a month in two weeks
yeah so it's fully booked up and you're
making i mean you said average is about
775 a month at fully occupancy is over a
grand
so absolutely incredible what will be
your words of advice to somebody wanting
to do service accommodation wanting to
do this what would you say 100 educate
yourself first invest in yourself
because
it doesn't you're not going to learn
everything from videos from other people
you need to invest in yourself right get
educated because things we went through
in this property if we didn't have gone
to your courses for example we wouldn't
have known what to do if you want to see
more videos like this subscribe hit the
like button drop a comment and we'll see
you next time well done thank you